[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat avec à mes côtés
oriane mancini bonjour oriane gentiment
est notre invité cette semaine et
olivier jacquin sénateur socialiste de
la meurthe et moselle bonjour à vous
bonjour et cette semaine christophe
castaner et nicole belloubet et est
auditionné à l'assemblée nationale sur
les violences commises lors des
manifestations du 16 mars dernier à
christophe castaner s'est félicité de sa
nouvelle doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
après un acte 19 mieux maîtriser le
sénat a donné un coup de frein 80
km/heure gauche et droite réunies ont
voté l'assouplissement de la mesure
contre l'avis du gouvernement et ce dans
le cadre de la loi mobilité qui sera
votée mardi
après les citoyens et avant les
conclusions de l'exécutif c'est au tour
du parlement de s'emparer du grand débat
deux journées entières ils seront
consacrés dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
prochaine puis les 9 et 10 avril edouard
philippe viendra s'exprimer devant le
parlement
mais déjà les groupes politiques
affûtent leurs propositions
et pour commencer retour sur l'audition
de christophe castaner et nicole
belloubet à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le ministre de l'intérieur et la garde
des sceaux était entendu par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale mercredi une semaine plus tôt
christophe castaner avait été chahuté
lors d'une audition similaire au sénat
quelques jours après un acte 18d gilet
jaune particulièrement chaotique cette
fois après un acte 19 mieux maîtriser le
ministre s'est félicité de ce que la
nouvelle doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
et selon lui porté ses fruits mais les
oppositions demeure avec beaucoup
d'interrogations résumé signé maïté
frémont les députés voulaient eux aussi
avoir des réponses à leurs
interrogations
une seule et même question pourquoi y
at-il eu des dysfonctionnements le 16
mars dernier pour les ministres
certaines consignes n'ont tout
simplement pas été respectés de ces
dernières semaines nous avons assisté à
un véritable travail de sape
concernant l usage d armes
intermédiaires ce travail de sape a eu
de conséquence sans doute de mauvaises
consignes concernant leur usage voir une
retenue des forces de l'ordre je crois
qu'il ne faut pas avoir d'états d'âme
quand il s'agit de rétablir l'ordre
républicain et c'est ce que nous avons
demandé au préfet de police
les ministres donnent une doctrine et
des grandes orientations
ensuite ils traitent avec les préfets de
zone nous donnons ces instructions
ensuite chacun les fait redescendre à
son niveau notamment au préfet et chaque
préfet organise ensuite avec les forces
le bon système de fonctionnement une
explication bien loin de convaincre
certains députés
on se gargarise aujourd'hui du succès
cette nouvelle doctrine avec simplement
si j'ose dire un samedi de succès entre
guillemets pour le terme de succès pour
moi aujourd'hui l'état a perdu sa ford
dissuasion quand vous ne prenez pas vos
responsabilités politiques il est normal
que l'administration se cherchent à se
protéger de ce qui aurait été votre
première critique sert qu'arrive une
bavure l'objectif pour le gouvernement
est clair que ce 16 mars ne se
reproduise s'il ya quelqu'un ici qui
peut prétendre que deux mais n'y aura
plus de problème c'est mentir aux gens
par contre il faut se donner les moyens
et c'est ce que nous tentons de faire
avec le préfet de police j'ai donné des
instructions extrêmement précises aux
préfets de police pour que la demande de
manifestation sur les champs-elysées
samedi prochain ce qui n'est qu'une
provocation à de nouvelles violences
interdite nicole belloubet a pour sa
part dressé un bilan judiciaire depuis
quatre mois de mobilisation
plus de 9000 personnes ont été placées
en garde à vue et 2000 condamnations ont
déjà été prononcées
olivier jacquin ce que selon vous le
gouvernement eut raison de durcir la
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
personne ne peut se satisfaire des
casses scandaleuse qu'il y avait je
trouve pas très respectueux là il vient
de nous faire une démonstration de ce
qu'on appelle ce que le président de la
république a critiqué comme étant la
république des fusibles
il nous explique que c'est pas de sa
faute c'est la force des forces de
police c'est pas respectueux de
l'engagement énorme des forces de police
et de gendarmerie
c'est pas respectueux non plus du droit
de liberté et de manifester nous balance
un projet de loi contre les violences
prétendument mais c'est contre la
liberté de manifester c'est pas
respectueux de ce très grand mouvement
populaire se réveille des classes
populaires autour des ronds point de
vouloir les amalgames et aux violences
et de ne pas traiter cette question
essentielle
vous ne croyez pas quand il dit que
certaines de ses consignes à paris n'ont
pas été respectées le 16 mars il se
dédouane à très bon compte ou ça vous
inquiète puisque étant que le ministre
dit je suis pas respecté sa cote de
popularité à christophe castaner est en
forte baisse
est ce qu'il est devenu une sorte de
mayom fait pour emmanuel macron j'ai pas
envie de stigmatiser de cette manière là
mais tout le monde a pu voir qu'il y
avait un énorme souci quand on fait
sauter un un préfet de cette manière là
pour protéger le ministre c'est
manifeste et donc il ya effectivement
comme vous le remarquez une faiblesse
notoire dans le dispositif
gouvernemental alors le sénat aussi un
mène ces auditions sur ces violences du
16 mars après christophe castaner et
bruno le maire la semaine dernière
c'était au tour des policiers d'être
auditionné cette semaine
mais pour le sénateur communiste fabien
gay
la réponse à cette crise elle ne doit
pas être policière mais social on écoute
tout ceci ne mène à rien c'est une
escalade pour ne pas répondre à la
question sociale vue pouvait en tout cas
faire tout ce que vous voulez voter
toutes les lois anti casseurs que vous
voulez en réalité cette colère sociale
est là et donc il faut y répondre il y à
des manifestants que je dissocie des
casseurs ça il faut condamner les actes
de violence mais en même temps il faut
répondre socialement c'est ça la
véritable sortie de la crise et que les
gens attendent parce que là vous allez
épuisé les forces de l'ordre ça fait dix
neuf semaines 19 semaines nous nous
sommes et nos femmes qui le composent
les forces de l'ordre sont épuisés ne
comprennent même plouay où ils vont ils
le disent d'ailleurs ce n'est pas la
matraque qui réglera ce problème c'est
bien une réponse politique alors olivier
jacquin plutôt qu'une réponse politique
pour l'instant le gouvernement
privilégie une réponse sécuritaire vous
le regrettez complètement je suis assis
en accord avec les propos qui viennent
d'être tenus
on sort nous de cette semaine de la loi
des mobilités y avait beaucoup de
réponses à donner en terme social et
revenir louis la crise la révolte elle
vient quand même
elle a émané du prix du carburant du 80
km/heure de choses comme ça d'une
incompréhension majeur des premiers de
cordée envers les dernier de cordée et
on ne va pas leur répondre à la matraque
ça ça marche pas la sécurité c'est la
première attente de nos concitoyens et
que ces mouvements ultra violents
d'extrême gauche d'extrême droite
viennent en profiter pour casser menacé
la république c'est inacceptable et ne
me dites pas qu avec les moyens qu'on
n'arrive pas à arrêter 1500 casseurs sur
les champs-elysées ça je sais pas
respectueux du professionnalisme des
forces de police et de maintien de
gendarmerie et de maintien ne pensais
pas que la loi anti casseurs issus de la
droite sénatoriale à laquelle la gauche
s'est opposée est une bonne solution
pour régler ses problèmes de violence
non c'est grave c'est grave cette loi
anti casseurs mais d'où venons nous
comme république
et comme démocratie un des fondamentaux
ça a été la révolution française
c'est un droit constitutionnel la
possibilité de manifester et tout ce que
l'on fait qui va menacer et a tenté à
douala va tenter aussi à la cohésion de
notre société on ne peut pas la museler
notre société il faut ma foi qu'elle
exprime et si un désaccord de fond
il doit y être répondu de manière
politique et non de cette manière là
j'ai mis sur ma carte de voeux cette
année une énigme africaine qui va
peut-être vous amuser faut réfléchir
deux secondes qui est plus fort que le
lion qui est plus fort que le lion c'est
la savane le plus fort des plus forts si
on lui enlève son milieu de vie il
disparaît la démocratie c'est pareil si
le pouvoir n'est plus en accord avec le
terrain ça ne marche pas c'est un peu
compliqué mais je crois que c'est
extrêmement intéressant de se rappeler
que le fondamental c'est toujours le
terrain qui doit avoir raison un dernier
mois j'aurai un dernier mot sur ce sujet
puisque le parlement auditionnera didier
lallement la semaine prochaine le
nouveau préfet de police de paris qu'est
ce que vous attendez de ses auditions
bas qu'il nous dise effectivement que
les consignes vont il va nous le dire
que le construit ni sont maintenant
parfaitement respectée mais c'est
marrant ils craignent tous beaucoup les
auditions au sénat
c'est plus confortable à l'assemblée
nationale non je profite de ça pour dire
que le sénat comme contre-pouvoir
s'affirme véritablement et c'est une
chose importante le sénat est
constitutionnellement et c'est normal
moins connu que l'assemblée mais le
bicamérisme c'est pouvoir afficher un
principe de contre-pouvoir alors
justement va parler du sénat puisqu'il
poursuivaient à cette semaine l'examen
de la loi mobilité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte fixe les grandes lignes pour
les transports de demain et cette
semaine les sénateurs sont revenus sur
une mesure phare de l'exécutif la
limitation de la vitesse à 80 km/heure
gauche et droite réunies ont voté un
assouplissement de la mesure contre
l'avis du gouvernement
jérôme rabier pour cette deuxième
semaine d'examen de la loi d'orientation
des mobilités le sénat a tenté de
renforcer les pouvoirs locaux dans de
nombreux domaines sur une mesure
sensibles comme l'abaissement de la
vitesse maximale à 80 km/heure
les sénateurs ont par exemple donner le
pouvoir aux conseils départementaux ou
au préfet de moduler la vitesse une
mesure de bon sens selon la majorité des
sénateurs
je ne suis pas contre la mise en place
de 80 km heure sur un certain nombre de
tronçons
on est pour la mise en application avec
intelligence et surtout faisons un peu
plus confiance aux élus locaux
la mesure a bien été voté par la chambre
haute mais contre l'avis du gouvernement
car si emmanuel macron avait évoqué ce
sujet lors de ses interventions récentes
la ministre elisabeth borgne a préféré
attendre l'évaluation promise par le
premier ministre donc dans la tente à la
fois de cette évaluation et de contes
conclusion du grand débat proposent le
retrait ce nom avis défavorable autre
sujet sur lequel les sénateurs ont
bataillé pour plus de libertés locales
l'encadrement des installations des
nouveaux moyens de transports en libre
service trottinette vélo scooter pour
les élus du palais du luxembourg
les villes doivent pouvoir encadrer leur
installation en leur permettant de
soumettre les opérateurs un régime
d'autorisation préalable que j'évoquais
et à des obligations portant entre
autres en plus de ce que vous proposez
sur le nombre maximal d'engins pouvant
être déployées et sur les
caractéristiques de ces engins ainsi que
sur le paiement de redevance
d'occupation du domaine public
autre sujet qui a divisé gouvernement et
senna la mise en place d'un forfait
mobilité pour tous les français pouvant
atteindre 400 euros par an objectif que
ceux qui n'ont pas de prise en charge de
leur employeur pour les transports en
commun se voient récompensés s'ils
pratiquent le covoiturage ou utilisent
leur vélo
gouvernement souhaite rendre le forfait
obligatoire mais qu'il ne soit pas
cumulable avec un remboursement des
transports en commun les sénateurs ont
voté un forfait facultatif pour les
entreprises mais avec possibilité
d'additionner la prise en charge
transports en commun et les autres modes
doux déplacement olivier jacquin sur la
limitation de la vitesse à 80 km/heure
en a vu le sénat l'a assoupli le
gouvernement a voté contre alors que
pendant ce grand débat emmanuel macron
avait semblé pour l'assouplissement de
cette mesure
mais hier emmanuel macron a dit qu'il
doit philippe avait eu raison d'être
ferme
est ce que vous y comprenez quelque
chose comme vous pas bien que c'est un
drôle de retour de bâton pour le
gouvernement cette histoire les 80
kilomètres heure ça a été le paroxysme
du jupiter isna un moment où ils se
croyaient tout puissant très très fort
au dessus tout le monde on décide comme
ça claque de balancer le 80 km savez moi
je suis la campagne quand on est à paris
ici 80 km heure je m'excuse on s'en
fiche on s'en fiche mais à la campagne
quand en plus on nous balance des taxes
importantes sur le carbone sur le diesel
ça ça a contribué énormément à la crise
donc là notre collègue qui a proposé cet
amendement je le vois comme un beau pied
de nez au gouvernement qui va devoir
revenir là-dessus s'empêtrer encore dans
cette crise d'autorité qu'il a eu sur 7
sur cette question particulièrement
percement reviendra dessus à l'assemblée
il ne suivra pas le vote du sénat
je ne sais le dire puisque il ya quand
même les chiffres la mortalité qui vont
intervenir en même temps que les radars
sont cassés ça rappelle tout le début de
la crise et on est effectivement sur un
sujet qui est compliqué à démêler oui
alors autre sujet la majorité de droite
a repoussé tous les amendements visant à
inscrire dans la loi l'objectif la fin
de la vente des véhicules thermiques
essence idéelle d'ici 2040 c'est une
occasion manquée excellente question
parce que un des points faibles de ce
texte de loi qui est passé en première
lecture au sénat
d'habitude on prend les textes en numéro
2 est là on se dit bon c'est quand même
bien la navette parlementaire que
l'assemblée puisse revenir sur ces
dans un excès de notre assemblée et
notre assemblée le sénat n'a pas entendu
le message délivré notamment par les
jeunes de dire mais la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique doit être une
priorité et on a été nombreux à proposer
que soit mis en cohérence les objectifs
les objectifs carbone à 2050 avec cette
histoire d'interdire le véhicule
thermique à 2040
on a failli gagner il y avait une
faiblesse de l'assemblée du dans
l'hémicycle à ce moment là qui s'est
traduite par un scrutin public c'est à
dire que quand la représentation la
présente montre une faiblesse ont fait
un scrutin public c'est à dire c'est la
théorie du sénat de la représentation
qui s'exprime
moi je bête est clair en gros bref les
républicains n'étaient plus assez
nombreux il faut un scrutin public qui
fait que c'est leur force numérique qui
l'emporté c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
repoussée
notre proposition qui ne venaient pas
des rangs socialistes on était très
nombreux à dire il faut envoyer ce signe
très fort à nos concitoyens à
l'industrie et surtout nous le disons
avoir des mesures d'accompagnement on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas faire de la
fiscalité ou des décisions punitive s'en
donner les moyens à chacun des français
là où il est de participer à ce grand
mouvement important et cette nécessité
de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et j'espère qu'à l'assemblée
ces mesures là seront bien rétabli et
affirmée alors des questions se posaient
sur le financement de cette loi on parle
quand même de 500 millions ce n'est pas
rien est ce que à l'issue de l'examen du
texte vous y voyez plus clair alors on
était en accord avec le rapporteur qui a
proposé de flécher plus de taxe carbone
sur les carburants latter icpe pour
financer cette loi non financées et il y
avait deux grands dispositifs pour les
infrastructures fils pouvoir financer
les infrastructures à l'objectif qui
avait été arrêté par le parlement et
puis ensuite est une autre mesure qui
est très intéressant dans cette eau et
je tiens à le dire la ministre borgne a
proposé que toute la france soit couvert
de collectivités compétentes en matière
d'organisation des transports
pour l'instant il avait essentiellement
dans les villes les très grandes villes
et dans les milieux peu denses il n'y en
avait pas et c'est une très bonne idée
je le dis de le prévoir
sauf que on a aussi proposé d'associer
cette semaine des financements à cette
mesure parce qu'on peut pas donner une
compétence sans les moyens de l'exercer
et là le gouvernement l'a attaqué alors
là je suis très très craintif
surtout ce texte il peut être analysée
sur des le risque de mobilité à deux
vitesses et entre espace danse et entre
espaces peu denses les choses sont très
différentes dans les espaces peu denses
et la voiture qui domine quand on est
ici à paris on n'a pas quasiment pas
besoin de deux voitures ça tout le monde
peut le comprendre dans les espaces
danse il ya une offre de mobilité
alternative de trottinettes de machin de
trucs énormes dans les espaces peu
denses y'a pas grand chose et il faut
des financements pour les espaces peu
dans sinon on aura donné une compétence
aux collectivités des espaces peu dans
ce sens les moyens d'exercer et on va
encore augmenter la fracture entre ces
deux types d'espacés nécessité d'avoir
ces financements elle et on en vient à
notre troisième thème la réponse
politique à la crise des gilet jaune
avec notamment cette proposition de loi
des républicains à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une loi à 10 milliards 10 milliards de
pouvoir d'achat mauvaise nouvelle elle
n'a pas été adopté mais ce n'est pas une
surprise elle émanait du groupe l'est
républicain l'assemblée et visait
surtout à mettre le gouvernement sur le
gris ré indexation des retraites des
allocations familiales annulation de la
hausse de la csg pour les retraités les
députés de droite voulait conduire la
majorité à une forme de mea culpa ils
ont été déçus résumé des débats en
commission
signée mari la bat avant même de
débattre du texte
majorité et opposition se sont affrontés
sur la politique d' emmanuel macron
at-il redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français depuis son élection à cette
question les députés ont débattu durant
près de deux heures
votre proposition de loi est probable
ont un contretemps pour le dire
gentiment si vous l'aviez fait bien on
aurait peut-être pu comprendre mais les
chiffres de l'insee viennent de sortir
ils sont indiscutables pouvoir d'achat
des français a augmenté de 1,1 pour cent
sur le quatrième trimestre j'entends que
cela vous fâchent mais notre volonté
c'est véritablement de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux français sans le
financé par la dette parce que jusqu'à
maintenant
en tout cas c'est tout ce que vous avez
fait financé par le déficit financé par
la dette puisque la dette a augmenté
depuis deux ans d'environ 150 milliards
d'euros à droite c'est une politique de
matraquage fiscal que dénoncent les
républicains leur proposition de loi
vise donc à redonner 10 milliards
d'euros de pouvoir d'achat aux français
compensées par des économies sur les
dépenses publiques
une stratégie contestée en commission si
on considère l'ensemble des mesures
proposées la réindexation des appels des
allocations familiales
l'annulation de la hausse de à ces
sujets pour tous les retraités
le rétablissement des plafonds du
quotient familial l'abaissement des deux
premières tranches d'impôt sevrés bref
c'est du lourd
l'addition est lourde
gouvernement s'est lourdement trompé
dans sa politique fiscale depuis
maintenant vingt mois c'est cela que
cela veut dire ça a une incidence sur la
vie quotidienne
on n'est pas dans un débat a été ré où
un débat totalement virtuel on est dans
la réalité de la vie des français et
nous essayons de rétablir un certain
nombre de points au terme du débat les
six articles se sont vu rejeter le texte
sera toutefois discuté en séance
publique le 4 avril prochain
mais le débat pourrait tourner court si
le groupe majoritaire déposent une
motion de rejet
alors olivier jacquin radix ation des
retraites annulation de la hausse de la
csg ré indexation des allocations
familiales une proposition de loi
finalement que les socialistes auraient
pu voter
on va voter pour mais on a fait une
meilleure proposition de loi nous dès
décembre 2018 les deux groupes
socialistes assemblée sénat ont fait une
proposition de loi pour améliorer le
pour la sortie de crise voilà elle
s'appelait avec tout de suite mais en
décembre on était des propositions moins
démagogique
excusez moi je suis un peu cruel mais
moi je suis d'accord qu'on redonne du
pouvoir d'achat aux retraités qu'on
baisse un peu l'impôt sur le revenu etc
mais quand on dit en même temps quand on
va le financer par une baisse de la
dépense publique
ça me fait l'impression qu'on donne
d'une main ce qu'on va reprendre de
l'autre pas aux mêmes exactement mais
c'est leur posture en permanente de dire
moins de dépenses publiques
et ça c'est un dogme ultralibéral moi je
suis pour l'efficacité de la dépense
publique ça n'est pas la même chose donc
moins de dépenses publiques
et dans le même moment chaque fois qu'il
ya une baisse de dépense publique
il hurle surtout quand ça concerne leur
territoire regardez les sur les petites
lignes ferroviaires ils ont voté dès
demain l'ouverture à la concurrence la
libéralisation et chaque fois qu'il ya
une fermeture de guichets
il hurle nous aussi on hurle mais je
pense qu'on est plus cohérent sur ce
point de vue là et par rapport à leur
proposition loi franchement ce qui a été
fait par un conglomérat 19 ong dont la
cfdt
la fmh atd quart monde
les propos des 70 propositions pour le
pouvoir de vivre me semble elle pleine
de cohérence et aller dans le bon sens
plus de justice fiscale et sociale alors
c'est au tour du parlement de s'emparer
de ce grand débat deux journées seront
consacrées à l'assemblée nationale
pudeur philippe viendra devant
l'assemblée nationale et devant le sénat
dans dix jours avec un débat derrière
qu'est ce que vous attendez du discours
du premier ministre
ah bah on attend on attend d'un premier
ministre un discours qui va porter sur
la réconciliation remettent de la
cohésion mais il semble un peu en froid
avec le sénat et j'espère que non mais
franchement fait référence à la faire à
la sphère benalla au fait que le sénat a
transmis les dossiers des huiles à
moteur de l'elysée et que de refiler pas
boycotter les questions d'actualité dans
la foulée c'est ça tout à fait ouais
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de son
attitude elle n'est pas satisfaisant du
tout non mais déjà ce grand débat et ce
questionnaire orienté qui pose les
questions de manière fléchés sur le rôle
du sénat qui n'interroge jamais l'elysée
alors que dans cette vème république
on peut s'interroger sur la surpuissance
jupitérienne de de l'elysée et ça
devrait être la vraie question plutôt
que d'interroger en permanence le
contre-pouvoir je pense que ce
gouvernement un problème particulier
avec la notion de contre pouvoir et ça
ne va pas du tout quand il dit la
question la réponse à la crise et
baisser le nombre de parlementaires non
qu'on pose déjà la question l'efficacité
du parlement relativement à l'elysée et
l'efficacité enfin l'efficacité générale
du parlement
c'est pas la réponse numérique elle
n'est pas la bonne réponse parce que si
vraiment le parlement ne sert à rien on
n'a qu'à
le réduire à rien juste un mot parce que
vous parlez du gouvernement un mot sur
richard ferrand qui lui aussi a annulé
deux déplacements communs prévu avec
gérard larcher il parle il parle de
politicaillerie quand il parle du sénat
gérard larcher s'en défend évidemment
nous avons fait le droit et jamais de
politicaillerie dit il que pensez vous
de l'attitude de richard ferrand bas
sont qualificatifs lui convient très
bien en termes de politicaillerie ils
insultent la constitution en disant ça
que le sénat aurait dépassé son pouvoir
moi je connais très bien les collègues
qui sont à la commission des lois dans
le style sérieux et expérimentés on fait
pas mieux ils ont surtout pas il savait
qu'il fallait pas franchir la ligne
rouge
mais il ya eu tellement d'excès commis
par le gouvernement sur cette fameuse
affaire des nanas et puis les affaires
récent qui n'ont pas eu besoin de
franchir la la ligne rouge donc là on
critique de cette manière là pour
ramener le débat loin des logiques de
contre-pouvoir et de constitution en dix
ans et du règlement de compte c'est pas
ça du tout le sénat a fait son boulot
dans ce domaine là et dans les autres
aussi aller à meaux pour pour finir les
missions liées jacquin d'une loi adoptée
cette semaine à l'assemblée nationale la
loi 100 qui a été adopté par 349 voix
pour 179 voix contre 40 abstentions loi
de transformation du système de santé la
ministre de la santé agnès buzyn s'est
félicité de l'adoption d'un texte qui va
sur leur permettre de lutter contre la
désertification médicale ce texte va
maintenant être examiné au sénat quelle
sera votre position
ben je pense que la position d'un
ministre était pas mal elle a dit que ce
texte avait besoin d'être encore
amélioré dans quel compte sur le sénat
pour l'améliorer et il y aura
effectivement à faire sur cette question
très sensible
j'aime bien raconter cette anecdote mon
fils était en stage aux états unis là
une otite à new york vous savez combien
ça coûte une otite à new york
d'abord on appelle papa pour savoir s'il
a une carte bancaire et puis ça a été
350 $ la consultation et 150 dollars
d'antibiotiques
donc je dis ça exprès parce qu'on a une
chance et on ne le rappelle pas
suffisamment d'avoir une santé gratuite
est plutôt de qualité ici alors moi je
suis élu rural j'étais président de
commune en commune dans un désert
médical et on a eu un mal de chien à
tenter d'inverser les choses et ça n'est
pas réussi ça fait dix ans de bricolage
autour de cette problématique des
déserts médicaux
en arrivant au parlement il ya un an et
demi j'ai remarqué à quel point cette
profession était organisée structurée et
forte politiquement et et on aura je
sais juste c'est la fin de l'émission
excusez nous lisez jacquin on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler quand le texte
arrive au sénat dans les prochaines
semaines merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous cette semaine un petit bois la
semaine prochaine
merci
[Musique]